foreign secretary is with us now mr rob
good morning to you
calling in the army what's all that
about that we're taking a series of
targeted proportionate focus steps
because although we've made huge
progress since the peak of the virus in
march
we can see the uptick and we need to
control it the virus
the the reality is there will be
stronger enforcement more powers for the
police
higher levels of fines mainly for the
small minority
who haven't complied always with the
rules we don't want them to blow it for
the vast majority of people and end up
in a second lockdown
the issue with the army is as throughout
this pandemic they've been used to
backfill
to support for example local authorities
with testing delivery of ppe
and if they can relieve any capacity for
the police to do the very difficult job
that they've done incredibly well
they'll be there to do that okay so not
on the streets as it were
the i think the suggestion being put
around by john ashworth that they're
going to be out patrolling is
uh frankly scaremongering okay um
it does look as though this i don't know
if you saw the latest yougov polder with
the snap pill that was out last night
the public supports the new covert
restrictions
but almost half then that they don't go
far enough also
the um developed nations don't think
that they go far
enough what else is in the arsenal well
we've always said we've got a sort of
repository of measures as you said in
the arsenal to take
um i don't think we're going to
speculate about what further could be
done
but the but the reality is they'll be
more intrusive
we could end up in a national lockdown
that's what we want to evolve
to avoid so for those that are saying
we're going to uh
too far what i would say is we've made
progress with the virus
as with other countries we've seen an
uptick we want to control it as we go
through the winter months which we know
are higher risk
we've got the the the measures that the
scientists have advised that we can take
and let's hope that we can get through
the winter months if we take these
measures if everyone
plays by the rules we go into christmas
not needing to go into that
national lockdown with all the impact on
society and families but also the damage
it would do to businesses
so our approach is focused balanced and
proportionate okay
so a second lockdown is still on the
card so a national lockdown
no we're taking these measures precisely
to
act at the the stitching time saves nine
that's what you're saying
we can't rule it out and what we want to
do is take every effort to avoid that
and that's why we're taking the measures
now some people will say we're going
we'll have the goldilocks criticisms too
hard to solve we looked at this very
carefully
we do think though now and as the you
say the public backer
taking early preventative measures to
make sure we get a grip back of the
virus to make sure it doesn't
expand uh to lose the sacrifices the
gains that we've made
in relation to the virus and obviously
we rule nothing out for the future but
i'm confident
that if everyone follows the new
guidance consistently
as the overwhelming majority have but
not everyone but if everyone now pulls
together as we
saw at the peak of the virus we'll get
through these winter months and there's
light at the end of the tunnel as we
go into next year the prime minister in
his recorded address to the four nations
last night
said that we have succeeded before one
wonders how
one of the world's worst death tolls can
be seen as success
well we've succeeded in getting grip of
this deadly virus
we've uh protected well we've
we've come through that major peak if
you look at the hospitalization rate the
fatality rate
we've we've got that right down but we
do don't want to see them uptick in the
number of cases
lead to that trajectory going back up
and i think
we've got now the measures in place to
make sure we can we don't lose the
sacrifices we don't lose the gains that
we've made
and we've also got schools open we've
got businesses open we've got the
hospitality sector open yes people
bristle a little bit about these extra
restrictions the
10 pm limits on bars and restaurants but
that's in order that we can
bank the gains we've made move forward
in a short footed and safe and
responsible way
not end up in a second lockdown i'm glad
you mentioned the pubs
closing at 10 i mean focusing on the
hospitality
industry of the new cases 729 according
to public health england up to the week
13th of september 45 of cases and care
homes 21
in schools 18 in workplaces 5
in pubs and restaurants and other food
outlets well we see nothing in the wrong
direction aren't we
not the wrong people no certainly right
to say
that those at greatest risk are the
elderly and those in care homes and
those with vulnerabilities
we've taken the measures around care
homes and the intra hospital infections
that we
saw at the the peak those problems of
course we're looking very carefully at
all of that now
but we also know the evidence from for
example the local lockdowns we had
in the north east and the midlands in
the northwest we've seen internationally
if you take belgium
that there is an increase in young
people spreading the
virus we know that in bars and
restaurants particularly after people
have had a few drinks
as you go into this as you go into the
later hours of the evening
that there's a risk that the compliance
with the guidance ebbs a little bit
so but this is so we're taking this
measure we're confident based on the
evidence we've got
domestically internationally that it's
one element of those that we need to
make but there's no
there's no silver bullet here um okay
and we are deriving different
lessons from different aspects of the
evidence and indeed the international
practice yeah but five percent
of cases were from food outlets and that
does include pubs
and restaurants well i'm not sure quite
the data you've got i trust it i know
you're reading it out faithfully but
we're looking at the
whole range of evidence that we've got
including where there's been
upticks in the virus in the localized
areas how we got back control
over the virus there and also
international experience particularly on
the continent
where they've had this uptick before us
so we know that for example the limits
on restaurants and bars
in belgium one element of what they did
was quite successful
in that respect but it's only one
element in the toolkit the arsenal that
you described that we're taking
okay what about people um who were told
that they
actively you wanted them to go back to
work you wanted 80 percent of whitehall
staff to be back at work by the end
of this month that has dramatically and
drastically
changed and the impact on residual
businesses like i don't know let's use
pret as an example
um and uh i don't know dry cleaners etc
etc whether football is just passing
football
they're done they're toast i do not was
at my local dry
cleaners in hersham asking about this i
totally get
those sectors that have really struggled
through this and will feel
uh that the change in guidance is
another bloat and we understand that
but we are taking these measures i do
think it's important you're right
there's a change in the guidance we're
following
the evidence we want to keep the uptick
that we've seen in the number of cases
and bear down on it keep that under
control bear down on it and
better that that we take these measures
now then we end up in a wholesale
lockdown
where those businesses can't operate at
all whether it's in the hospitality
sector the entertainment sector
or indeed in retail so there'll be money
to help these businesses although it's
been huge about 160 billion yeah but
will there be more money to help
them we're always looking the
chancellor's put a huge amount in place
i know
looking at my high streets i've been out
uh in in
all of them talking to retail that
they've really benefited
from the bounce back loans from the
grants from the exemption from business
rates but the chance was keeping all of
that
under constant review not just economic
wide
economy-wide but the specific sectors
affected including extending furlough
well we've saved 12 million jobs we've
got the
um the job retention bonus uh the
kickstart scheme so we're for now
we're we're we're looking at that but um
i don't think the chances minded to
wholesale extend the furlough scheme we
are looking at the targeted measures we
keep them
constantly under review and we've done a
great job
keeping those jobs and those businesses
alive through the
peak of the crisis and of course we want
us to keep afloat
as many of them as possible and i know
that's at the forefront of the
chancellor's considerations
with the future budgets and csr spending
review in mind
what about with the aviation industry i
mean one way to fix that without
offering them any money is to improve
the testing
system there has been a campaign via i
think the daily telegraph newspaper
where the former prime minister even the
former prime minister said that you
should
improve testing at airports or indeed
put testing in at airports and we don't
why not the the challenge is that the
false positive rate is very high so only
seven percent
of tests will be successful in
identifying those that actually have the
virus
so the truth is you can't just rely on
that and in fairness i don't think those
advocating
think that you can you'd still have to
rely on the self-isolation at home
and have further testing but why not do
that well actually that's what we have
we have
self-isolation at home and
we want to make sure we ramp up the
testing capacity to
alleviate that and other measures but
the truth is with test and trace and
they'll be
you know we we've we've made huge gains
over the last few months
we are prioritizing key workers on the
front line
nhs workers care home workers we've got
our testing rate per capita
is ahead of any other major country
ahead of all the other european
countries but we do have to look at what
we're prioritizing and what's going to
be
the most effective let's counter through
another couple of points and know that
your time
is tight what's going on with uh
football grounds first of
october large sporting events won't be
able to go ahead as planned what happens
if people want to go and watch their
football game
well look we've obviously got the
premier league started we've got
grassroots football
at amateur level uh that that is
proceeding we're worried about those
crowds we've got
we had a in place a system of pilots and
a phased approach
to having crowds back into the big
events like premier league football
we do need to put that on pause and it's
basically around avoiding
uh the kind of transmission amongst
large groups of people okay um
can i ask you to put your foreign
secretary hat on for just a couple of
questions if i may
ruth bader ginsburg yes um
her place on the supreme court will be
uh filled on
saturday that that is that does
certainly seem to be
distastefully quick of course you don't
want to get involved internal politics
of another country
but um having said that if um joe biden
wins he's going to look across the pond
and say
why didn't you support us well actually
uh you were absolutely right i'm not
going to get drawn into domestic
politics including
supreme court appointments um but i've
been out in washington i was
there last week uh we're obviously very
careful not to dip our toe into the
febrile waters of the u.s election but
we've got great relations
i've been talking to congress men and
women on the hill from republicans to
democrats we're very confident we'll be
a stalwart partner
to the u.s regardless of who's in office
either in downing street or indeed
in the oval office that's the nature of
that fellowship doesn't necessarily
agree and joe biden
agreed with her saying unless we if we
broke the law
yeah when it comes to the brexit bill
then they won't
do a deal with us well i met nancy
pelosi as i met republicans and she
underlined that and democrats so i think
the
it's right to say that um particularly
democrats in the irish lobbying congress
are concerned about what's happening
with brexit in fact that's been the case
right the way through it's my third
meeting
with richie neil who represents the
irish caucus and they made their
concerns clear it was also a good
opportunity for me to make clear that
the uk has absolutely and
unconditionally made clear that we will
respect the good friday agreement
that we would never erect any
infrastructure at the border between the
north and south
and actually it's the eu that hasn't
made that commitment
on their side so i think it was a good
opportunity to be clear on where we're
standing
but a ride across congress i can tell
you republicans and democrats
are excited about the opportunity to
engage with britain particularly on all
of our foreign policy agenda well we're
very like-minded
uh can i ask you about nazanin zagari
ratcliffe
of course our viewers will know her
husband was in here just last week
um she has complained that overnight
she's been harassed at home by
the iranian revolutionary guard have you
heard about it what are you doing about
it so
first of all my heart goes out to
nazarene i've spoken to a couple of
times over the summer because she's
under equivalent of house arrest we've
made it clear right the way through i've
spoken to
foreign minister zarif twice during
august and we're continuing to discuss
the the treatment of naznen and also the
other dual nationals
uh in detention is arbitrary uh they
need to be released they need to be
returned home
and in terms of what the most recent
thing we've done is
i've teamed up with my french and german
counterparts we've de-marched
the iranians on human rights but also
specifically
the detention of nationals and dual
nationals in iran
we continue to make it clear that the
treatment of nazanee
and all of those brits uh dual nationals
in particular
is utterly unacceptable one of the
things that might help is the 400
million quid or thereabouts that we
owe the uh iranian government we accept
that we owe them that money
for tanks uh uh pre the revolution uh
back in the
late 70's um the debt the defense
secretary said that we are heading
towards paying that where are we
well there's been a process been ongoing
it's not linked but it's in parallel
where we've been saying look we
recognize this debt and we'll uh
we'll look at how we can resolve it as
best we can there are all sorts of
challenges to doing that
not least the sanctions regime uh that
is in place including
uh from the u.s but frankly that isn't
an excuse
for the uranus we said that we would
make steps to resolve it
um well when we can um but
well look there's some litigation that
has been ongoing
uh there's all sorts of logistical
challenges in delivering it
but frankly that is separate from the
clear and immediate obligation
on the iranians to uh to not to detain
british nationals including dual
nationals arbitrarily and not
as you've described engaging this cat
and mouse exercise with nasalin in
particular
and certainly we've been abundantly
clear
that it will be beyond the pale for her
to be returned to detention at this time
quick thought before i let you go um on
a personal level are you worried about
um the flu vaccine are you going to have
a flu vaccine this this winter yes
absolutely as soon as possible
okay uh are you worried about catching
food i've booked into one on friday oh
are you
um maybe i'll have one as well um as a
result of that i'll say the foreign
secretary says he's having one so i'm
going to have one are you worried about
catching covert have you had it already
um i i haven't had an
antibody test but every time i've had
symptoms i've
either self-isolated and then had a test
and so who knows um
i mean before the lockdown in
march in in in back in february i had
some of the symptoms and you never quite
know
from the swab tests you're looking
really poorly in the house of commons
well but look i've been tested a number
of times including when i went to the
states
and i'm free of code